je vous déclare memre d'honneur je ils
prête serment sur une boule de billard
et portent leur peignes en sauttoir
quand les chauves ne se cachent plus ils
s'associe en confrérie il ne peut pas
encore accéder au gras de chauve
couronné parce qu'il a encore trop de
cheveux ici donc il doit être patient et
moyenant la patience et les années ben
peut-être qu'il arrivera à monter de
grade puis vous avez un chauff couronné
ici sans tricher les cheveux sont partis
sur le sommet et reste sur le côté et
puis alors notre idéal à tous c'est de
venir chauffe intégrale notre cher ami
Ernst si je vous dis le mot perruque
vous me dites quoi ah perruque c'est
quelque chose qui me rend un petit peu
agressifin c'est une notion qu'on aime
pas trop belge allemand ou français le
club est prêt à accueillir toutes les
nationalités évidemment pas de risque de
cheveux sur la langue dégarni et fier de
l'être au point d'antonet leur hymne
international bra